[موسيقى]
جئت لا اعلم من
اين جاء لا يعلم من اين لكنه هنا
[موسيقى]
يقولون نحن لا نذ احدا لا نسرق ولا نقتل
لا نرشي ولا نحقد لكننا لا نؤمن بما
تؤمنون هم الملحدون كيف يعيشون في
المجتمعات العربيه لماذا يخيفون ومما
يخافون الملحدون كيف يراهم الشارع العربيه
في فلك الممنوع
لنشاهد بقولك ايه ايوه انا ملحد على
فكره انا اعارض شغل الالحاد شو الالحاد
ماذا تعني كلمه الحاد بقول لك انا ملحد
ملحد تعرف شو يعني ملحد يعني ما ما ما
معترف بوجود ربه بالتاكيد يعني حيكون شاز
ولن يتقبله المجتمع ولا باي حال من
الاحوال يا عم بقول لك انا ملحد انا ملحد
ايوه يعني عايز ايه الانسان الذي لا يؤمن
بالله فنحن نعتبره كافر طفيلي عايشين
بالحياه بس لازيه البشر انا لما اشوف حدا
ملحد بحاول قدر الامكان اني انا اتجنبه او
ما اخطط معه كثير او ما اخذ يعني نقاش طب
والمصحف الشريف انا ملحد حرام يعني مزراب
هن الملحدين دول الواحد ما يحاول ان هو
يتناقش معاهم اصلا لان هم ليهم معتقدات
احنا كمسلمين مش شايفين ان هي ليها اساس
اصلا من الصحر هو بقوللك كل انسان يعني
بنولد على الفطره كمان اوعى تكون نسيت اني
ملحد فكره الالحاد هنا مش مش جايه من من
من ايمان يعني هم مش مؤمنين قوي بان فعلا
مافيش اله لا هي ف فكره فكره غربيه اصلا
انه ما بنوا بشيء اسمه الرب ما بنوا بشيء
اسمه يسوع ما بنوا بهالاشياء كلها ما
بامنه الا بحاله جئت لا اعلم من اين ولكني
اتيت وزي ما هو عنده حريه يكون ملحد انا
الي حريه الي حريه اكون مؤمن لا هم ناس
وعندهم افكار ونحارب الفكر بالفكر ما فينا
نعن في هدول الاشخاص يعني بهذا الشكل اذا
بدك فينا نعمل لهم
يعني نقنعهم بشي تاني ونتعلم برض معاهم
برض بالسياسه وبلين الو الو الو الو الو
الو انا ملحد انا ملحد هو حر بس ما تستعرض
يعني لا تستعرض قدام الناس انك انت ملحد
وما بتامن انا ملحد يا عالم انا ملحد يا
هو انا ملحد يا ناس هذا مش كافر مرتد شويه
هيك يعني فممكن بالكلام الحلو بالكلام
الطيب ممكن اصير يعني تعاللي
بقى
سيداتي سادتي ضيفنا اليوم اضطر الى الرحيل
من وطنه لانه اشهر الحاده قاسم الغزالي
حقوقي مغربي وناشط في مجال الحريات
الفكريه والعقائديه قاسم انت اول مغربي
يجاهر بالحا دفعت الثمن لجوءا سياسيا في
سويسرا تقول انا لم اختر ان اكون مسلما كي
اترك
الاسلام لست اول ملحد ربما لكن ربما كانت
قضيتي هي اثارت الكثير من الاهتمام خصوصا
في وسائل الاعلام
المغربيه انا لم اختر اكيد ان اكون مسلما
انا ولدت في مجتمع او في بيئه يعتبر الدين
فيها مكونا من مكونات الهويه والانتماء
وهذا للاسف نوع من انواع الاستبداد اي ان
السلطه
السياسيه التي تتخذ شرعيتها انطلاقا من
الدين
استعمل سمم تستعمل الدين ك كنوع لتثبت
هويه او اخلاص
اوصل انا حينما رفضت الدين حينما رفضت
الدين فانا برفض الدين لم ارفض فقط
الايمان وانما رفضت مجموعه من القيم ورفضت
ايضا نظام سياسي معين على
مستوى متكامل ديني سياسي اجتماعي طيب
لماذا رفضت لماذا رفضت الين قاسم لماذا
كيف توصلت الى يعني فكره انك لا تؤمن او
انك غير
مسلم يعني هذه لم تاكتي يعني بين عشيه
وضحاها مساله عدم الايمان هي تاخذ مراحل
من التطور ومراحل من التفكير ام في
البدايه كنت طفل صغير يعني ك اي طفل اخر
في الوجود يسال وهو في عمر سبع سنوات او
ثمان سنوات من خلق الله والقمع الذي تجابه
به حينما تسال هذا السؤال يدل الى حد ما
على هشاشه فكره الله ام لانه اذا فتكبر
بداخلك الاسئله وتتساءل دائما فهنالك من
يجد اجابات جاهزه هي الايمان والدين وقصه
الخلق الى اخره وربما يكون مسار اخر انا
بدات اقرا وابحث فوجدت ان فكره الدين او
فكره هي فكره للخلاص يعني فكره تقدم تصور
معين للحياه لم تقنعني ووجدت انني ان
استمر في البحث يعني ان ارمي بعقلي في
معترك الافكار والتفكير وان لا اصل الى
نتائج محدده او معينه وفضلت عدم الايمان
ليس فقط بالاله الابراهيمي ولا اعتقد انني
بحاجه الى خالق لكي اوجد في هذا الكون ا
بمعنى قلت في البدايه لا يعرفون من اين
اتوا وهل يعرف المؤمن اين اتى ام هي فقط
مجموعه دع
نسال علم يمكن اثباتها وعلميا لايمكن
نقاشها فتبقى هي
مساله فلذلك هي ايمان وليست حقيقه علميه
بالنسبه اليك طيب دكتور طارق ابو النور
الامين العام للمجمع الفقهي الاوروبي
المستقل للدراسات الاسلاميه الماليه طبعا
انت خطيب وامام مسجد
ايضا دكتور طارق انت تعتبر ان الالحاد
ظاهره خطيره تتفشى اكثر فا اكثر وسط
الشباب المسلمين اليوم برايك اشخاص مثل
قاسم الغزالي يشكلون خطرا على المجتمعات
المسلمه الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
مولانا رسول الله واله وصحبه
ا اولا اولا لابد ان نفرق بين قضيه فرديه
حريه فرديه الله تبارك وتعالى يقول لا
اكراه في الدين ويقول عزم قائل انما انت
مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر ويقول اخيرا
افانت تكره الناس حتى يكونوا
مؤمنين الدين جاء ليربط الخالقه المخلوقه
بخالقه وجاء ليسعد لا
ليشقي من اجل الشقاء والايات الكونيه
الايات النفسيه سنريهم اياتنا في الافاق
وفي انفسهم حتى يتبين لهم انه الحق هته
الايات الكونيه هي بحد ذاتها دليل على ان
هناك خالقا دعا قادرا مدبرا حكيما من اراد
ان ينكر هذا فله ذلك هذه حريته الشخصيه
وانا كحريت شخص هو
خطر لا لا ي هذ انتم تسمونها ظاهره الا
وتعتبر انها خطره على المجتمعات لماذا هلا
فسرت لنا لماذا هي خطره اذا كانت تدخل ضمن
اطار الحريات الشخصيه كما
تقول الحرب ضد الدين الحرب ضد
الاسلام والمسلمين هو الخطر لابد ان يكون
هناك تعايش لابد ان يكون هناك احترام لا
يمكن ان يدعي انسان ما ولا اتكلم عن الاخ
الذي بجانبي اتكلم بصفه عامه لا يمكن ان
يدعي انسان ما انه يعتقد بشيء ما وهو في
نفس الوقت يحارب الاخرين و يعني ويريد ان
يفرض ما يعتقده او ما يرى انه حق على
الاخرين هذا يعني الالحاد بالنسبه اليك هو
جزء من الحرب على الاسلام اليوم نعم اظن
دعنا نذهب عبر الاقمار الصناعيه الى
العاصمه المصريه دكتور سعيد صادق استاذ
علم الاجتماع السياسي في الجامعه
الامريكيه بالقاهره انت تتهم التيارات
السياسيه الاسلاميه المتشدده بابعاد
الشباب عن الدين وبحثهم على
الالحاد شوفي ظاهره الالحاد ليست جديده
يعني هي في التاريخ موجوده حتى قبل
الاسلام كان في حركه الدهريين في ظل
الاسلام طلعت حركه او بعض الاشخاص
المشهورين ابن اليندي
وغيرهم يمكن في العصور الحديثه هناك عده
اسباب لهذه الظاهره انها بدات تلفت
الانتباه في وسائل الاعلام العربيه
والدوليه على هذه الظاهره يمكن ليها عده
اسباب السبب الاول العولمه عولمه الاعلام
اصبح الان ممكن انك انت تردي لان لما
تنظري في الفضائيات حاليا ممكن تلاقي
فضائيات اسلاميه وفضائيات مسيحيه وما شابه
لكن مافيش فضائيات لهذا التيار فطبعا
استغلوا هم وجود ان في امكانيه انك يبقى
عندي منابر اعلاميه ومنصات اعلاميه على
اليوتيوب على تويتر على فيسبوك ويعبروا عن
رايهم لان هم اصبحوا كمان بيهاجموا هم
طبعا قمعوا
واعتقلوا وقتلوا احيانا يعني للاسف
ليس هم فقط يعني لازم ننظر الى الصوره
بصوره كامله ما هو وضع الاقليات الدينيه
في الشرق الاوسط ما هو وضع المسيحيين
البهائيين
اليهود اليزيديين يعني تدخلهم تد الاق هو
وضع كل العلمانيين كل هذه الاقليات
الدينيه بتعاني من معامله او استخدام سواء
من قوى جماعات سياسيه دينيه او حتى
الانظمه الانظمه ساعات بتستغل هذا الموضوع
لقمع المعارضه بصوره عامه ما هو بسهوله
جدا ممكن تنتهي باي واحد ان هو ملحد لكن
هو بينتقد النظام فقط او ليه موقف من
النظام جدا ان انت تحولي الموضوع كله الى
دين والحاد لان الثقافه الدينيه في الشرق
الاوسط لان طبعا احنا مجتمع الدين بيلعب
دور اساسي فيه ومهم جدا طيب بما انك اشرت
الى ذلك دكتور سنكمل بما انك اشرت الى ذلك
يعني اشرت الى اهميه الدين دعونا مشاهدينا
مع الضيوف نتعرف على راي الدين في الفيديو
التالي نرصد لكم حكم الاديان السماويه
الثلاثه على
الملحدين ماذا يقول شيخ مسلم وراهب مسيحي
وح خام يهودي عن الملحد
لنشاهد
الاسلام يرفض طبعا الالحاد بالله بلا شك
الملحد مريض اخرج منه المرض مجتمع المدينه
في ايام النبي علسلم كان هكذا فيه
المؤمنون فيه اليهود فيه المسيحيون فيه
اللادينيين فيه
الوثنيين الاسلام كمجتمع لا يرفض كدين
[موسيقى]
يرفض هنالك خيارات قد تكون خاطئه لدى
الانسان منها خيار الاحاد او عدم الايمان
ان كان الالحاد فعلا يعتبر خطيئه فنحن
ندعو الى توبه هذا الملحد وان كان خيارا
حرا فنحن ندعو الى توعيته بضروره ان يعرف
بان هنالك خالقا
[موسيقى]
للكون هذوك الحم 2000 عام كان الحد حرم
ولكن
الحخ هذ 2
[موسيقى]
عامال بلاصه
لهيب
يم بين وبين الله وانش
على الملحد انه حرام عليه كل اسرائيل
عندهم بلاصه الجنه حط كان
ملحد الذي صنعه
الرب تهلل
به قاسم الغزالي باختصار لدينا ثلاث دقائق
قبل نهايه هذا الجزء الاول باختصار شديد
موقفك واحد من كل الاديان انت كملحد يعني
انت بطبيعه الحال موقفي واحد من كل
الاديان لكن بحكم انني من خلفيه اسلاميه
وبحكم انني من مجتمع اسلامي وبان الاسلام
ايضا يساهم في تلك النظره السلبيه وفي انه
يتهمني بانني خطر او انه ايضا على المستوى
التشريعي مستوى الحدود مابدل دينه فاقتلوه
وهذه قراء التقليديه عفوا فقط دقيقه فقط
وهذه الت قراءه التقليديه للدين التي هي
منتشره كثيرا انا اعرف ان ربما الاستاذ
طارق لا يقبل بهذا المبدا ولا يؤمن بان كل
شخص يجب ان ان يتم قتله ولكن دعني اسال
دكتور طارق ورد في تقريركم الرجل الدين
الازهري وصف الملحد بالمريض لكنه اعتبر ان
المجتمع الاسلامي يقبله الدين لا يقبل
الفتاوى اليوم تعتبر ان الالحاد هو رده ا
يعني هو مرتد الملحد والمرتد فعليا يقتل
وفق ما قرات اجماع الائمه هل انتم توافقون
على هذا ارجع دائما النصوص بطبيعه الحال
لا يمكن لمن هب ودب ان يستفتى فيها وان
يقول عنها ما شااء النصوص لها قواعدها
ولها
اربابها مثلا نص وثيقه المدينه هي خير
دليل وثيقه حينما جاء رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم الى المدينه وثيقه المدينه كانت
اول وثيقه مكتوبه اعطت الحقوق لجميع
الاقليات الدينيه وعاش المسلمون مع غيرهم
في المدينه المنوره وهي الاصل والعاصمه
للدوله سلام وامن اولا
ثانيا لا لا انا انا ج جايك يعني ثانيا
وهذا امر مهم جدا باختصار ابن رشد القرطبي
في كتابه بدايه المجتهد ونهايه المقتصد ل
هو كتاب جليل في فقه المقارن تكلم عن حديث
الذي ذكره الاخ وقال ان العلماء وبالخصوص
علماء المالكيه في ذلك العصر يعني منذ
1000 سنه يعني فصلوا في هذه المساله
وفصلوا بين المرتد المحارب والمرتد الغير
المحارب وكذلك المذهب الاخرى لان هذا كتاب
فقه المقارن يعني نعم ف المرتد المحارب هو
الذي يحارب لا يكتفي فقط بفكره شخصيه وب
حريته الشخصيه بل يحارب يحارب الاخرين
ويتعدى على حقوق الاخرين فبهذا يحاسبه من
يحاسبه السلطان
بمقتضى الاحكام التي هي سلطانيه وليست
لليس منهب ودب يطبق مف الحرب مفهوم الحرب
هنا جد فضفاض فانا اذا قلت لماذا انا ملحد
فمباشرة
الى امور ثيولوجيا والى امور فكريه
وفلسفيه التي تعتبر ازدراء للاسلام لان في
موضوع الاسلام اذا نقشت انا مثلا الله
وقلت انا هذا الاله التقليدي هذا الاله
الذي يشبه احد ملوك عصره كيف صور في
القران وكيف صور مثلا في الحديث فهناك من
سيتهمني بزرا الاديان وساعت محارب واذا
قلت انا مع حق الناس في التخلي عن الاسلام
وفي اعتناق المسيحيه او في او في ان
يعبروا عن مواقفهم بكل جراه من النصوص
الدينيه التي تعتبر مقدسه فالن يعتبر ذلك
ازدراء للدين الن يعتبر ذلك حربا لض
الاسلام شيء اخر فق يجيب لس يعني هذه
المساله في عاد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حاور نصارى نجران حور نصارى نجران عن
طبيعه الاله نعم فلم يتهمهم بازدراء الدين
وكذلك التابعين وكذلك مثلا الامام ابن
حنبل حينما حاور المعتزله وحاور غيرهم في
طبيع التاريخ اليوم هذا موجودك هذا يثبت
لا يدع مجان للشك ان العلماء العاملين
كانت لهم دائما مجال وسيعه طيب
لح بابن رشد ونعرف ان محنه ابن رشد كثير
عنها انا اقول ان هذا الطرح الحداثي الذي
تقدمه يا استاذ هو طرح مهم جدا وانا معه
رغم انني ملحد لانني انا ليست معركتي ضد
الاسلام او ضد الدين انا معركتي من اجل
التعايش من اجل وكنك تعتبر انه غير موجود
على ارض الواقع الاحاديث الدينيه النصوص
القرانيه يتم استغلالها او يتم استعمالها
من اجل تبرير الفاصل سحد كل صوت يرفض
الايمان شد بالتفاصيل عن ذلك بعد الفاصل
مشاهدينا كاميرا في فلك الممنوع سجلت
شهادات مع ملحدين عرب من تونس مرورا بعمان
وبيروت وصولا الى غزه بعد الفاصل ايضا
نعرفكم على سعيد بن جبلي مغربي اسلامي
سابق يروي قصه تحرره من الدين على حد
تعبيره في فلك الممنوع نعود بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل m